moral clarity is its duration its
conviction it's the ability to
reasonably persuade other people of
moral positions but it's something that
can't be defined in absolutely general
terms because what's important about
moral clarity is you only get it case by
case most of us are willing to agree on
general principles life liberty pursuit
of happiness as a set of them I can give
you some other ones most of us also will
disagree on certain extreme cases moral
clarity however is about looking at each
particular case looking at all the facts
looking at all the contexts and working
out your answers and the call for moral
clarity which the right has overtaken is
a very important one because I think
people have moral needs we deeply want
to be moral people we want to see
ourselves as moral people I think the
right often confuses moral clarity with
moral simplicity and thinks that you
know a couple of straightforward rules
will give it to us that's a mistake
so moral clarity is something that you
have to get piece budgets
whether or not new words at all and it
would like good evil hero Noble they're
very old-fashioned words I'm giving them
a different a different set of content
and I'll give you one example the word
hero which I think we're all quite
nervous about using because most of us
think Rambo or blood-and-guts or
Superman when we think about heroes
there is room for a notion of
enlightenment hero and I've taken that
notion all the way back to the Odyssey
where and as a matter of fact the
disagreement about what a hero is goes
all the way back to the ancient Greeks
Greeks you have in Homer who wrote our
very first novels you have the idea of
Achilles right the warrior hero who
rushes into battle and is overtaken by
rage and dies a glorious death and
Odysseus who's wise perhaps wily crafty
people are always a little bit
suspicious of him because he comes out
alive and I find that extremely
interesting because I think we're
suspicious of heroes who aren't tragic
heroes we think that nobody could be a
hero if they don't die in a blaze of
glory that they must have done something
wrong I think why suspiciousness is also
a way of reassuring ourselves that we
don't really need to do anything heroic
we focus on the heroes who died
tragically we tend to ignore the ones
who lived successfully fully human with
faults we're not talking about gods here
or icons remember the word icon comes
from a piece of religious art which is
two-dimensional okay two dimensional and
two dimensional not because the
byzantines didn't know how to paint in
three dimensions they did it was a
prohibition that they actually took on
themselves because they didn't want
images to be too lifelike heroes
are different from icons and that they
have flaws they have weaknesses ranging
from major to minor ones but if we
accept that we also have to accept the
challenge that all of us can be heroic